I have a cringe-worthy bit of audio and
video for you today Donald Trump called
Apple CEO Tim Cook Tim Apple Tim Cook is
really well known in the business world
and Trump likes having business people
around the White House now a lot of them
can't stand Trump so for example Elon
Musk bailed out of participating on some
kind of business advisory panel for
Donald Trump other CEOs have also said I
just can't work with the guy but anyway
Donald Trump was able to get Tim Cook to
go to the White House for something
called the American work force policy
advisory board and he called him Tim
Apple and I'm gonna play the video for
you twice in a moment the first time I
saw the video I thought maybe I heard it
wrong or maybe Donald from Studdard or
anything other than Trump called the guy
Tim Apple but he did he called him Tim
Apple and the look on Tim Tim Cook's
face sort of says it all you will also
notice that Ivanka also seems to kind of
like a slightly perk up who is for
whatever reason there as usual I don't
know why she's there Jared Kushner's
they are unelected and not confirmed by
the Senate advisers but ok they are
there here is Donald Trump referring to
Tim Cook as Tim Apple we appreciate it
very much Tim Apple but we appreciate it
very much Tim Apple but this is just the
best and hilariously this this has
happened before
once Donald Trump had some kind of event
with Lockheed Martin's CEO Marilyn
Hewson and he referred to her as Marilyn
Lockheed check it out we have some of
our great business leaders and leaders
period right behind me I may ask Marilyn
Lockheed the leading woman's business
executive in this country according to
many this is just the best of course
she's the leading business executive
woman's business executive in the
country according to many more people
who actually know her real name rather
than
Marylyn Lockheed is it possible that
Trump thinks since his businesses are
all called Trump whatever that every
business is named after the person
that's running the business or something
like that there's a report that Bill
Microsoft is now refusing to even meet
with the president after this incident
and Mark Facebook Berg is going to have
to face really tough questions from
Trump at the White House very very soon
I read something that's kind of an
interesting take on this which is that
this is a either conscious or
unconscious sort of psychological
domination game that Donald Trump is
playing that it is a way of showing that
he doesn't even need to call people by
the right name that to him they are
simply the CEO of the company
you're basically Tim Apple you're just
Tim the CEO of Apple you're Marilyn
Lockheed as he said it doesn't matter
what your actual last name is you're
just Marilyn the CEO of Lockheed Martin
it's an interesting take but I think the
more realistic scenario is that this is
part of the cognitive decline that so
many people have been observing in
Donald Trump and which we will be
following up on with a psychiatrist dr.
John Gartner very soon sooner than then
before you know it
John Gartner will be back on the program